let's do a couple of problems where we
estimate or predict answers to questions
using linear models linear models and it
sounds very fancy but what a linear
model is is just using a line to
describe some trend in data and with our
linear models we will do a little bit of
interpolation interpolation and a little
bit of extrapolation you might have
already heard these words before in your
everyday life
extrapolation extrapolation and these
interpolation means trying to estimate
what happened between two data points
we're going to do a couple of examples
of that in this video an extrapolation
means well see what the last few data
points were and see what that trend look
like and then keep on continuing that
trend and see what might happen if we
were if that trend were to continue and
I'll show you some examples of that so
let's do some example questions here so
I have this chart here median age
remember median is the middle so if I
have you know if I have the numbers 3 7
& 9 the median is the median is the 7
it's the middle the middle age so this
is the median age of males and females
at first marriage by year so if we just
look at this data right here if we look
at like 1900 the average man was getting
married or not the average the median
male so the middle man was getting
married at around the age looks like at
around the age a little over 25 almost
26 while the median woman the median
woman was getting married looks at
around 22 or 23 years old and as we went
through the century those ages got lower
and lower and lower until we got to
about 1960 this problem is interesting
irrespective of the actual problems it's
just interesting to see this trend that
at the beginning of the century people
got married you know reasonably similar
to when they're getting married right
now but there was kind of a minimum
point there was an around the 1960s
people got married at a younger age and
this was true for male and females and
you can all
so see back here the age difference
between the median male and the median
female that's just gotten smaller and
smaller over time now it's really small
so these are just solved interesting
things from this chart this is the
actual data from that chart so actually
I didn't even have to estimated here in
1900 in 1900 the median male a the
median age of males getting married was
twenty five point nine that's that right
there and the median age of women
getting married was twenty one point
nine that's that over there so this is
just a scatter plot of this data we've
just plotted each of these points over
here these in blue these in red now
let's do the questions use the data from
example one this is example one up here
to estimate the age at marriage for
females in 1946 fit a line by hand to
the data before 1970 so what they want
to do is they want me to look at all of
the data before 1970 so let's see this
is 1970 right here
that's 1970 right there and they want to
fit a line by hand to the data before
1970 you know what they mean is that I'm
going to do it I'm just going to eyeball
it but they want me to do is fit is to
draw a line that gets as close to all of
this data before 1970 as possible so it
can't go through all of these points
because all of these points don't sit
exactly on one line but let me try to
draw a line or a linear model for the
data from what is this 1890 all the way
to 1970 so I'm going to try my best to
draw a line here that gets close to all
of these points it won't be able to go
through all of them all the way to 1970
maybe a line would look something like
that let's let me draw a better one than
that let me draw it in red because we're
dealing with the red data so I want to
go all the way to 1970 it would have
been nice to have a line drawing tool
maybe the line might look something like
that there are actual mathematical ways
to figure out the the best fit line on
this we won't go into that right now
that's called
regression but I just eyeballed it that
line looks like a pretty good fit for
all of that data none of the data is too
far away from that line so that's what
they mean by fit a line by hand to the
data before 1970 this is the data before
1970 and then this if we assume that
this is a good linear model for that
data we can use it to estimate we can
use it to estimate the age at marriage
for females in 1946 1946 is C this is
1950 this would be 1945 1945 would be
right over here so 1946 would be right
right over there
so if we wanted to estimate that if I
were to draw a I were to figure out
where that hits the vertical axis that
seems to hit the vertical axis that
seems to hit the vertical axis at around
I don't know my best guess is let's see
I should have sumed in more hits it
right about there
this is 22 and 1/2 so this looks like
maybe 20 and a half because this would
be maybe 20 and a half years maybe so
I'll call it twenty point five years
obviously I can't do it exact but you
get the idea I am interpolating I am I
am looking at well I'm here I'm using
the model to do it I won't use
necessarily the word interpolation yet
we're going to do it a much more direct
form of interpolation and then later on
in this video but here I fit a line and
then I just used that line as a model to
estimate when what was the median age of
women in 1946 let's do Part two use the
data from example one to estimate the
age at marriage for females in 1984 fit
a line by hand to the data from 1970 on
in order to fit estimate this accurately
so now they want us to fit a line from
this data on so let me make a line so
fit a line by hand from the data 1970 on
so let me try to draw a line that gets
close to all of these points it gets
close to describing all of these points
maybe it looks like something like that
not all of them sit exactly on the line
but they're all pretty close and if we
assume that the
is a good linear model I haven't done it
mathematically I'm just doing I'm
eyeballing it let's see what it would be
in 1984 this is 1990 so 1984 is going to
be right around right around there so
that looks it looks actually it looks
amazingly similar to the median age of
men in 1970 so we can actually get the
exact number it's about 23 point two so
this looks to be about twenty three
point two twenty three point two years
now part three use the data from example
one to estimate the age at marriage for
males and nineteen ninety five use
linear interpolation now we're going to
do a more direct form of interpolation
we're not going to use a linear model or
we're not going to fit a line we're use
linear interpolation between 1990 and
2000 data points so we're looking at men
now so I'll do it in blue between 1990
that is 1990 and that is 2000 for men so
if I were to draw just a line there we
could assume that the trend would have
looked something like that between 1990
and 2000 and they want us to interpolate
what happened in 1995 so 1995 is that
point right there so this is pure
interpolation we're using the data point
in 1990 and the data point in 2000
drawing a line between them and assuming
that 1995 would have been right in
between them we are interpolating
between the 1990 data and the 2000 data
so if you were to if you were to try to
estimate where that is it looks like
it's a little bit over 26 and actually
if we say that it's right in between
these two values right there it'll be
twenty six point four or five years
twenty six point four five years if it's
exactly in between 1995 is exactly 5
years from each so twenty six point four
five looks pretty good now let's do
another example so here's a percentage
of women smokers by year and yeah I have
to say these charts are interesting in
and of themselves you know notice in
1990 there were a good number of women
who are pregnant who smoked
now almost what 18 or 19 percent of
pregnant women smoked in 1990 and now
that's down well this is 2004 so
hopefully that trend this trend is
continuing to go down of entry to zero
percent but it went down to 10 percent
so there still are a percentage of
pregnant women who for unfortunately
smoked so let's use let's do these
problems use the data from example two
that's this right here to estimate the
percentage of pregnant smokers
in 1997 use linear interpolation between
the 1996 and 2000 data so 1996 and 2000
data we're going to use linear
interpolation so let me draw a line now
and you could always do this much more
exact if you have better tools or a
spreadsheet but I'm going to draw a line
and I want to get 1997 so 1997 1997 1997
it's going to be right this is 1997 it's
going to be right over there if we use
linear interpolation we are
interpretating between that data point
and that data point it's a linear
interpolation we assume it's a linear
trend between the two and so this looks
like it's let me go all the way over
here looks a little bit more than 12 and
maybe 13 maybe 13 percent is my best
estimate now part 5 use the data from
example 2 same example right here to
estimate the percentage of pregnant
smokers in 2006 there isn't any 2006
this chart ends at 2004 so we have to
use linear extrapolation with the final
two data points so this here you're
going to see the difference we
interpolate and an extrapolation
interpolation you are estimating between
two data points that you are new
extrapolation we're going to take the
final two data points and we're going to
continue that line we're going to
extrapolate that line so if you were to
just continue this line between the
final two data points it might look
something like that
so if you had 2006 out here these are
going up by two so 2004 2006 we
extrapolate this line the percentage of
women smoking might be well it looks a
little bit it looks a little bit under
10% so maybe
nine and a half percent once again it's
just an estimate but we're just
extrapolating the trend we're assuming
the trend of the last two data points
continues and then using that it would
be around nine and a half percent in
2006 now maybe you know that's not
definite a definite the only prediction
you could make you could do a Lin you
could extrapolate based on all of the
data and get a line that looks something
let me try to do it a little bit better
than that that looks something like that
and then this line would predict a lower
smoking rate so it depends on what data
you use what you're using to do your
linear model with and how you're
extrapolating it but anyway hopefully
you found this useful